super excellent merci à qui on est fier
d'être ici à montréal pour soutenir
l'équipe de france peut vous dire qu'ici
les gens sont à fond pour la finale au
tout consommer les colis m pap et je
m'entends ou pas la pression est total
pour voir le match attend tu vas faire
la moustache suicide quand même y est
super bon single dans n'importe quel bon
le match va commencer on descend de la
voiture que vous et qu'on est en train
de se dire on se rappellera toute notre
vie ce moment et on dira toute notre vie
tiens c'est nulle trace et d'envoi le
match d'élite qui maintenant veut gagner
[Applaudissements]
non
audrey
si on va voir c'est son projet sur
celles à moi tu es la seule arme est la
seule et pourquoi
au syndicat lance était palpable hier
robert
[Musique]
non non non non la lola et quatre
excellents superbe france on donne le
prolétariat duteil la fameuse humoriste
française et salue les fans de no no
qu'est ce que tu faisais tout seul je me
promenais pour trouver mes dernières
tenues point d'appui à la golf incrusté
sa promo dans le plan exact
bonjour à tous on est à la banquise
apparemment c'est le lieu pour manger
une pizza la meilleure poutine de morale
paraît-il moi c'est très simple je vais
prendre la classique car je suis un
homme qui n'a pas de personnalité
est ce que vous savez que le perche man
cette vidéo études ipad nous rejoindre
nous sommes avec tulalip haye
je fais avec une équipe de baseball à
balle molle de balle molle voilà qui
s'appelle balle molle c'est pas cette
barrière c'est quand on voit les règles
mais je mettrais sous titres
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alexis braud un vrai tarnac officiel
celui-là on l'a pas forcé est sorti tout
seul mon dieu
voilà de quoi nourrir ma famille pendant
six mois
c'est donc ça la fameuse poutine du
québec aller 3 2 1 les gones mais j'aime
tellement ce alors qu'au québec
mais moi j'adore mais je suis vraiment
fan de l'accent québécois alexandre est
pas de parler québécois pense pas qu'on
se moque c'est parce qu'on adore le
faire en fait
alors aujourd'hui on ne devrait que
s'appelle des piknic électronik wawa
sache il ya beaucoup de musique électro
les teufeurs leur drogue la musique
électronique
danser toute la nuit sur des sons techno
mais qu'est ce qui les motive
[Applaudissements]
chirac voilà tu as tu magazine nouvel
endroit tu trouves tulle sa patte dans
ce sens là
je tenais je tenais donc je ne crois pas
en tout cas ça c'est un crissement bon
c'est normal c'est christ un bon crise
mais bon j'aime telmap solo depuis plus
de 30 ans les teufeurs ne s'arrête plus
de danse et parcourront les festivals
aux quatre coins du monde
du coup deux premières impressions wouah
ça défrise à tomber le fromage à la
présence que c'est vous c'est tout ça
n'a pas besoin de chercher midi à
quatorze heures apparemment clémente est
vraiment pas de pièces de monnaies toi
[Musique]
regarde au ralenti pour parquer des
interdictions de remonter ça je crois
qu'il faut expliquer la base donc
l'acteur n'a mis que tu vas donc attaché
tu pourrais dans la rue comme ça je
prends du plaisir on voit les pressions
de plaisir et si tu veux pas on te
gratter le nez ou le visage commandement
qui est obligé de
ah merde il ya les avantages des
inconvénients
c'est quoi bonbons qui bonbons days
c'est comme ça qu'on dit bonjour je suis
un gladiateur et non on est dans une
salle degand fille 2 h rassemblement
lancé dh extrêmement saillantes et
violente d'accessible la manière de
combat barre est-ce que vous êtes prêts
juste à temps va-t-on j'adore en fait
être très violent et c'est parti voilà
l'ennemi n'ait pas tué j'ai perdu ma
bouche de 1 mm au côté droit
c'est vrai mais quand on regarde les
films jamais le mec qu'il arrive comme
ça y est c'est pourquoi c'est rouge j'ai
beaucoup misé dans le mille en fait paul
[Musique]
wasicka dangereux imagine juste et
cammas je suis moi y est j'ai reçu un
mail
[Musique]
wen en plus des mois la base c'est une
qualité a fait l'annoncé de swing c'est
plus une forme de demain la robuste
qu'on s'appelle ça je pensais vraiment
que c'était un stylo un stylo jeu avec
michael qui me balanger on a ça dans
cette tâche il a carrément le tatouage
de la hache sur le krach doit pas
vraiment intérêt à le mettre dans le
mille en toi tu appelles règlement ne
faut pas jeter une hache
hong kong ça va aussi me voilà on a
appris à lancer dh je sais pas quand
dans la vie ça peut te servir mais si un
jour une demande de tuer un mec avec une
hache quoi faire mais chez le père bon
je pense que ça se voit mais ma coupe de
cheveux mais je suis malade qui est
responsable
ceci la climatisation chaud froid chaud
froid tu es malade comment bien [ __ ]
mais peu de vacances
je suis chez le médecin ici à montréal
et ici tourner porte un masque quand on
consulte le médecin l'impression que je
suis un zombie infectés donc je pue de
la gueule
il ya un grain il a appelé very bad trip
vrai vous
c'est commencer fasse un film aussi ses
rapides et dangereux non mais quand ce
magma rapides et dangereux 8 des
sonorités très très québécoise
merci ahmed pour se battre pour ce
voyage en fait pour ce cette trempe de
culture qui nous offre c'est quoi ces
véhicules qu'avant culte c'était un
scooter électrique qui va à peu près une
vitesse de 30 km h avec dérapage
contrôlé aujourd'hui à montréal on avec
des gens qui font du gn du grandeur
nature en gros il se déguiser en
personnage un peu heroic fantasy ils se
battent pour de faux avec des armes qui
ne tue pas allons à leur rencontre
des doubles un des ogres des orques
c'est parti moi ces grumes en surnomme
la chaux léger pas ma voix que je suis
habituellement parce que c'était comme
ça et à quel moment c'est que le mec il
est mort alors avec les pointes vite et
des points localisés et or deux points
au broc trois points au torse
sais tu pas les deux points au breuil
battu par tombereaux cantona bat avec
lebron des points aux jambes agence
arrive que des gens quittent le cocon
dire il lâche le truc qui sont plus du
tout aux erp et uva et uvb c'est à
parler normale et oui ça on appelle sow
l'iran du style ça vous soulevez c'est
pas le fait qu stein mutuel c'est qu'on
lit un drame signé entre amis une fois
qu'on est sur bordeaux autour d'une
bière mais l'on pense une vidéo qu'on a
vues sur youtube
1 c'est quoi ça you to want you tube non
non c'est même un téléphone
il y en a qui appelle seule tablette
magique on sent on dirait pas comme ça
mais la caméra mais c'est très très mou
de plus nous leurs sinon mon personnage
celui que je jouerai en ce moment ce
serait plutôt
un humain malak c'est un fou un peu une
règle comme jean jusqu'à de mettre mon
poing en l'air pour the transparente et
le monde ne me vois pas donc si jamais
met en position l'appui filaires comme
ça me fait pour vous et que le gars qui
sont avec toi il est censé savoir
ouais de faire oui les personnes ici je
crois va d'ailleurs comme ça exactement
[Musique]
je vous du elle tend à mais non mais
d'abord battez vous je vais me faire un
mcdo j'arrive à
silence
on a perdu en gros là oui on va sentir
battant et je crois qu'elle arme alors
ce que ce temps de mener ancré dans ses
buts en tout cas ok je suis paré lander
[Musique]
la bataille
merci à tous
trois grues je te remercie je n'ai plus
mon masque mai dernier n'a rien fait
blesser un petit bonheur possible comme
ça qu'on dit on part en fait dans le
milieu
top silva il m'a dit avant de partir je
laisse ce si c'est les couilles de
grumes c'est à dire les couilles de son
personnage ou c'est la première fois
qu'on m'offre des coûts d'entretien mais
je jamais réussir à finir ça c'est
beaucoup trop
ça manquait deux choses un petit peu de
ketchup vous n'avez pas du sucre en
poudre messac
la mutuelle a fait trois ans et pas
assez de pluton prendre un petit peu
trop non plus bon j'espère gagner
toilettes à proximité mais qui en
vacances juste je déconnecte ya plus de
forte taille de nos jeux vidéo
en france et ça ça ne va pas du tout
mais pas du tout alors il ya hakim ait
ahmed qui mon propre au pied en disant
que j'étais sans doute meilleur que moi
en ping-pong correctement je fais le
magasin de sport et j'ai acheté ce si on
se rappelle ce fabuleux match comme
celui-là nous là où j'ai perdu envie
secondes
alors si jamais je gagne tu m'as un
poste installé en dur bon je tourne mais
qu'en fait je veux vraiment inspiré de
vie depuis début et c'est grâce à lui
que j'ai fait j'ai six graignes tu dois
commencer débit de youtube par
l'excellent super aux [ __ ] terminé à
terme et chaque vidéo par j'adorais
porte de sortie
ces dames le pari est tenu
de ta mère
non
ciao
[Musique]
c'est ma chance du débutant quand même
ok c'est anodin c'est fait hakim 2000
c'est fait ça va je me fais bien humide
je sais ce que tu possèdes victoire des
mois non c'est lui qui va devoir faire
le piquage donc cette vidéo vous allez
voir comment elle va commencer le super
tu veux
on ne va pas une musique de gros films
de cul et pourtant il s'agit de mario
tennis terminait bon j'ai perdu mon
époque on a testé la poutine québécoise
ça c'est fait la major largeur on a put
un de bien manger
mario a refusé carrément genre tabarnak
en fait et vous vous êtes bien manger en
effet en tabarnak vie dans les
commentaires - photo qui est venu me
voir je peux redire qu'il m'aiderait
mois ces malwares
en fait j'ai vu que c'est notre tour
chabot et pourquoi pas qui fait penser à
la ouate
je crains c'est mon chat pierre phrase
du monde très bien donc c'est quoi ton
expression à culte québécoises ont pas
s'enfarger dans les fleurs du tapis
maison pourquoi s'embarrasser des
détails ce soir aux mecs merci pour fait
un col bernard pivot
pourquoi dès que je fais un blog à
l'étranger les conditions
météorologiques catastrophiques ça là
bas j'ai halluciné souvenir qu'il
propose
tu vois un petit remake bonne chère un
frisbee en fête du canada j'espère tu
prends en faire bon usage le chapeau
tant que personne ne portera dans sa vie
une seule fois le cadeau pour les gens
de 90 ans
n'empêche tu vois cet objet avant qu'il
soit utilisé on peut vraiment le malaxer
se passe à la phase à venir va s'achever
sa a aucun problème en fait c'est après
que c'est sale c'est qu'on a un rendez
vous urgent était alors un petit type de
drogue
aujourd'hui on va faire du bon hockey
sur glace est-ce que vous êtes prêts ok
c'est parti donc quand on fait du pdu
alors qu'il se regarde on se protège
parce qu'on va se faire péter la gueule
tout simplement à la chaux nommé bien
moulé ouais super style être avant même
que sur la glace est un gros con c'est
sûr c'est ton projet j'ai sans cesse pas
colossaux si on allait chercher ça de
loin la victoire
un clic ou non j'oubliais on sent qu'un
nid au rugby mieux vaut savoir le grand
moment est arrivé
3 août ah oui ça que vous vous êtes mon
premier but des autres et j'ai
maintenant j'en ai rêvé toute ma vie et
je vais le faire
et des joueurs et joueuses ça va très
très vite dans la glace
ouais je sens que tout le monde si je
fais une chute elle doit être
extrêmement violente un des très rares
bulles en train de suer comme un fort ce
matériau dont et comme elle passe de mai
quand même qu'en fait on se mélange à
pinos heures c'est un roubaisien est ce
que tu fais là
c'est comme ça
et enfin la technique des nageurs de
roller pedrosa merci à tous d'or tu
cette vidéo merci à tous les poteaux
qu'ils ont actualisé au québec nous ont
très bien reçus et j'espère qu'on va
revenir prochainement ce petit chat
obama
andré porte
[Musique]